>> Tucker: A GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT." WHEN
ELON MUSK ANNOUNCED HE WAS
BUYING TWITTER, IT WAS PRETTY
OFFICE IS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WOULD BECOME UNHINGED, NOT JUST
ANGRY OR ANNOYED BUT
INSTEAD TO COMMIT LEGITIMATELY
TERRIFIED AND HYSTERICAL.
IMAGINE HOW YOU WOULD FEEL IF AN
ARMED INTRUDER BROKE INTO YOUR
HOME 3:00 IN THE MORNING. YOU
COULD KNOW WHERE THINGS WERE
GOING BUT YOU WOULD BE DEAD
CERTAIN EVERYTHING IS AT STAKE
HERE THAT HOW DEMOCRATS FEEL FEL
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS
AT STAKE. JOE BIDEN CANNOT
CONTINUE TO CONTROL THIS COUNTRY
IF YOU HAVE FREE ACCESS TO
INFORMATION. THAT SIMPLE. IF BIN
IS NOT IMPROVING YOUR LIFE AND
IS NOT EVEN TRYING TO IMPROVE
YOUR LIFE. SO THE BEST HE CAN DO
IS LIE TO YOU AND DEMAND THAT
YOU BELIEVE IT. BUT TO DO
THAT, HE NEEDS TO MAKE SURE
NOBODY ELSE CAN TALK BECAUSE IF
HE WERE TO HEAR THE TRUTH, YOU
MIGHT NOT OBEY. HOW IS BIDEN
GOING TO PULL THAT OFF? IT IS
NOT EASY. ONE OPTION WOULD BE TO
GET MEN WITH GUNS TO TELL YOU TO
SHUT UP. MOST AMERICANS HAVEN'T
THOUGHT OF THAT BECAUSE THIS IS
IN AFRICA OR EASTERN EUROPE.
THIS IS AMERICA AND WE DON'T DO
THINGS LIKE THAT HERE AND NEVER
HAVE. MORE PRECISELY, WE HAVE
AND UNTIL NOW. BUT NOW JOE BIDEN
AS PRESIDENT, EVERYTHING IS
DIFFERENT. SO TODAY, THE HERALD
COMING OF THE NEW SOVIET UNION,
THE ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED ITS
OWN STREAK OF TRUTH. THIS WILL
BE THE DISINFORMATION GOVERNANCE
BOARD. LAUGH IF YOU WANT BUT
JUST TO SHOW YOU THEY ARE NOT
KIDDING AROUND HERE, THIS PORT
IS NOT PART OF THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OR ANY OTHER AGENCY
ON FOREIGN THREATS FROM ABROAD.
NO, THE DISINFORMATION
GOVERNANCE BOARD IS PART OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
DHS IS A LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
DESIGNED TO POLICE THE
UNITED STATES AND BY THE WAY
A FAMOUS STOCKPILE OF
AMMUNITION. SO, IT IS NOT A JOKE
AT ALL. DH SECRETARY ALEJANDRO
MAYORKAS.
>> WE HAVE JUST ESTABLISHED
MISINFORMATION GOVERNANCE AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY TO MORE EFFECTIVELY
COMBAT THIS THREAT, NOT ONLY TO
ELECTION SECURITY BUT TO
HOMELAND SECURITY. >> Tucker:
OH, SO ONE OF AMERICA'S TOP
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS BUT
ACTUALLY, WE WILL BE POLICING
WHAT YOU SAY, TOTALLY NORMAL.
BUT HERE IS WHAT HE DIDN'T SAY.
DISINFORMATION AFFECTS HOMELAND
SECURITY AND AHEAD OF HOMELAND
SECURITY SO PRESUMABLY HE WOULD
KNOW SINCE ASSESSING THREATS TO
HOMELAND SECURITY IS HIS JOB.
BUT WHAT HE DIDN'T TELL US IS HS
DEFINING THIS INFORMATION HERE
AND SO WE HAVE THIS NEW AND
TERRIFYING THING. THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS SO CONCERNED
AND CREATE A NEW AGENCY TO FIGHT
IT BUT MAYORKAS NEVER HINTED TO
WHAT IT MIGHT BE. SO THE MAN IN
CHARGE OF DISINFORMATION
GOVERNING BOARD NEVER DEFINE
DISINFORMATION. IT IS ALMOST
UNBELIEVABLE WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT IT. WOULD YOU DECLARE WAR
ON A COUNTRY YOU COULDN'T NAME?
WOULD YOU SENTENCE SOMEONE TO
DEATH FOR A CRIME YOU COULDN'T
DESCRIBE? OF COURSE YOU WOULDN'T
IF YOU WERE A DECENT PERSON. YOU
CAN'T HAVE JUSTICE WITHOUT PREC
THAT IS WHY WE HAVE VERY LARGE
BOOKS OF LAW THAT DEFINES WHAT
IS ALLOWED AND WHAT IS NOT. BUT
THEY ARE NOT DEFINING THE CORE
CONCEPT AT THE HEART OF WHAT IS
EFFECTIVELY NEW A
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. MAYBE
THAT IS BECAUSE MAYORKAS DOESN'T
WANT JUSTICE AND NEITHER DOES
THE PRESIDENT WHO SERVES. THEY
WANT POWER AND TO GET POWER THEY
PLAN TO CONTROL WHAT YOU THINK.
WATCH MAYORKAS' POINT.
>> WE HAVE SO MANY EFFORTS
UNDERWAY TO EQUIP LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND IDENTIFY
INDIVIDUALS WHO VERY WELL COULD
BE DESCENDING INTO VIOLENCE BY
REASON OF IDEOLOGIES OF HATE,
PULSE NARRATIVES, OR OTHER
DISINFORMATION AND
MISINFORMATION PROPAGATED ON
SOCIAL MEDIA AND OTHER
PLATFORMS. >> Tucker: OH, DID
YOU KNOW THAT? SO ONE OF THE
BIGGEST LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
SAID IN WITH GUNS AROUND THE
COUNTRY DOING SO MANY THINGS TOP
DISINFORMATION AND POLSON
NARRATIVES. THOSE ARE NOT EVEN
LIES. JUST DEVIATION FROM
IMPROVE SCRIPT. AND AGAIN MEN
WITH GUNS "PLAN TO IDENTIFY
INDIVIDUALS WHO COULD BE
DESCENDING INTO VIOLENCE, COULD
BE DESCENDING." NOT PEOPLE WHO
COMMIT A VIOLENT OR ACCUSED OF A
CRIME AT ALL. DHS IS INSTEAD
GIVING LAW ENFORCEMENT POWER TO
PUNISH PEOPLE WHO THINK THE
WRONG THINGS. THAT WOULD BE
OPPONENTS OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION. IS THIS
DYSTOPIAN FICTION?
KNOW THIS IS HAPPENING IN FRONT
OF US. THAT MEANS JOE BIDEN'S
ENEMIES OR OFFICIALS OF THE
STATE. HOW WAS THIS HAPPENING IN
AMERICA? GOOD QUESTION, BUT IT
IS HAPPENING. AND BIDEN'S HAS
BEEN REAL, 33-YEAR-OLD HIGHLY
SELF-CONFIDENT WOMAN AND SHE
COMES FROM A PLACE CALLED THE
WILSON CENTER. A NONPROFIT NAMED
FOR AMERICA'S OTHER MENTALLY
INCAPACITATED WARMONGER BIGOT
PRESIDENT. IRONICALLY BECAUSE
EVERYTHING IS AN IRONY. CENTER
IN ITSELF DISINFORMATION BUT
THAT NEOCON VARIETY AND FOR THAT
REASON HEAVILY FUNDED BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION. ALSO
BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS CONNECTED
TO A FORMER ADVISOR TO THE
NEOLIBERAL GOVERNMENT OF UKRAINE
AND TENS OF BILLIONS OF TAX
DOLLARS TO THE ECONOMY THAT
SWIRLS DOWN THE DRAIN. SO YOU
CAN'T MAKE ANY OF THIS UP. IT IS
TOO GROTESQUE AND DO YOU BELIEVE
IT IS A NOVEL? NO YOU WOULDN'T.
THAT IS THE BAD NEWS. THE GOOD
NEWS IS EVERYONE INVOLVED IN
JOE BIDEN'S NEW MINISTRY
INFORMATION IS A BUFFOON. THEY
MAY BE EVIL, BUT THEY ARE ALSO
RIDICULOUS. THE MOST RIDICULOUS
OF ALL. SO YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT
HER APPOINTMENT AND
"THE WASHINGTON POST"
IMMEDIATELY THOUGHT OF KB
BECAUSE WAV COULD NUKE K IN V,
AT THIS HEIGHT OF THE PURCHASE
NEVER DID KARAOKE AND TOO
DIGNIFIED FOR THAT. BUT SHE
HAPPILY DOES. HERE SHE IS.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: FOR SINCE THE POINT
OF THE SHOW THAT WE ARE MAKING
THIS UP AND IT'S NOT HAPPENING
IN THE COUNTRY BUT IT IS
HAPPENING. THAT IS NO
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL. IT IS
ALSO THE PERSON YOURSELF AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO BRAGS A MASTERS
DEGREE FROM GEORGETOWN
UNIVERSITY. IN CASE YOU ARE
WONDERING THE ENTIRE ACADEMIC
CREDENTIAL MACHINE WITH THE
RULING CLASS IS IN FACT A JOKE
SPOILER, YES, IT IS A JOKE. THIS
IS SOMEBODY SO YOU USEFUL
SKILLS THAT SHE DESCRIBES
HERSELF IN THE FIRST WORDS OF
HER OWN BIO AS A
"INTERNATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
EXPERT ON DISINFORMATION." AS IF
THAT IS A DROP OF SOME SORT.
IMAGINE IF ONE OF YOUR KIDS GREW
UP TO BE INTERNATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED EXPERT INFORMATION.
THE SHAME YOU WOULD FEEL, THE
PAIN OF KNOWING THAT
UNEQUIVOCALLY YOU HAD FAILED AS
A PARENT. AFTER ALL THOSE YEARS
OF ADVANCED EDUCATION, SHE
BECAME AN EXPERT ON
DISINFORMATION. NOT ONLY THAT,
SHE CAN'T EVEN RHYME VERY WELL.E
SKILL THE PURPOSE FOR WHICH SHE
WAS HIRED WITH PARTISAN ATTACKSN
THE OTHER SIDE AND THAT IS
HER REAL JOB. YOU MAY HAVE
NOTICED IF YOU LISTEN CAREFULLY
THAT EVERY EXAMPLE OF
DISINFORMATION WITH KARAOKE
PERFORMANCE CAME FROM PEOPLE WHO
OPPOSE JOE BIDEN'S POLICIES. IS
THAT A COINCIDENCE? PROBABLY
NOT! IN FACT WE KNOW IT'S NOT
BECAUSE SHE IS TELLING ALL THE
DISINFORMATION IS ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE POLITICAL DIVIDE,
LISTEN.
>> THIS OF THE DISINFORMATION WE
HAVE SEEN IS HIGHLY MANIPULATIVE
CONTENT IS COMING FROM THE
RIGHT. TOP TEN MOST ENGAGED POST
ON TWITTER ANY GIVEN DAY USUALLY
POST COMING FROM THE RIGHT AND
JUST DEAL WITH HIGHLY EMOTIONAL
RHETORIC.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: YOU WOULD HAVE TO
LIVE IN A SELF-AWARENESS VACUUM
YOU MIGHT EVEN HAVE TO GO TO
GEORGETOWN UNIVERSITY. THE RIGHT
FIELD AND HIGHLY EMOTIONAL
RHETORIC.
[LAUGHTER]
SAYS ANITA JANCO BITS. IT IS
HARD TO KNOW THAT THIS SAME
WROTE AN ENTIRE BOOK ABOUT HOW
WOMEN CAN'T USE THE INTERNET
BECAUSE IT'S TOO UPSETTING FOR
THEM, THEY ARE TOO FRAGILE AND
IT MAKES YOU FAINT. HERE IS A
DIRECT QUOTE, "TO BE A WOMAN ONY
DANGEROUS ACT.
[LAUGHTER]
KEEP IN MIND IF YOU ARE A LADY
AND YOU ARE TO I DON'T KNOW
PORTER HUBER EATS, YOU ARE
EXPOSING YOURSELF TO DANGER.
THIS IS THE SAME WOMAN ANITA
JANKOWITZ IS TELLING YOU THE
RIGHT FOR EMOTIONAL RHETORIC!
NOW TO BE FAIR, ANITA JANKOWITZ
EXPECTS A LOT OF PEOPLE TO READ
THAT IN HER BOOK BECAUSE I READ
HER BOOK AND A TOTAL OF TWO
INTERVIEWS ON AMAZON. WE DID
READ IT AND I WILL GET TO WHAT
WE FOUND AND WHAT WE CAN EXPECT
FROM NEW ADMINISTRATIVE TRUTH
UNDER ANITA JANKOWITZ. BUT
FIRST, IT IS NECESSARY TO KNOW A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THIS
PERSON AND JUST NOT SIMPLY A
HYPOCRITE AND SHE OBVIOUSLY IS,
SHE WOULD BE TOO DENSE TO
UNDERSTAND BUT WHAT SHE HAS
IS FOR THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
SHE'S DONE THAT JOB FLAWLESSLY,E
DISINFORMATION HUNTER ONCE
CALLED THE HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP
STORY WHICH ENTIRELY TRUE, TRUMP
CAMPAIGN PRODUCT AND IN
OCTOBER 2020, VOTERS TO CONTEXT
AND NOT A FAIRY TALE ABOUT A
LAPTOP SHOP. NOW, DID SHE GIVE
US THE CONTEXT OR FACTS? DID SHE
DELIVER OF THE TRUTH NO, OF
COURSE NOT SHE JUST READ A BUNCH
OF WISE PEOPLE HE HANDED TO HER
ON A CARD AND SHE'S AN IDIOT.
NOW SHE'S LAW ENFORCEMENT. NINA
JANKOWICZ IS REPEATING A WILL
LIE WIDESPREAD ON THE EVE OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION AND WHEN
SHE REPEATED IT AND MADE IT
POSSIBLE FOR JOE BIDEN TO REPEAT
IT ONTO THE PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE
AND IN CASE YOU FORGOT, HERE IT
IS.
>> THEY ARE A 50 FORMER NATIONAL
FOLKS THAT SAID WHAT SHE IS
ACCUSING ME OF IS A RUSSIAN
PLAN. THEY HAVE SAID THAT THIS
HAS ALL FOUR OR FIVE FORMER
HEADS OF THE CIA. BOTH PARTIES
TO WHAT HE IS SAYING IS A BUNCH
OF GARBAGE. NOBODY BELIEVES AND
EXCEPT THOSE IN HIS GOOD FRIEND
RUDY GIULIANI. YOU MEAN THE
LAPTOP IS DOWN? THE RUSSIA
RUSSIA RUSSIA HOPES?
>> SAYS IS EXACTLY...
>> Tucker: JUST TO BE CLEAR,
THIS IS A NIGHTMARE UNFOLDING IN
SLOW MOTION, BUT THIS IS THE
POINT WHERE WE HAVE TO DRAW THE
LINE. NO, JOE BIDEN YOU CAN'T
HAVE A FEDERALLY FUNDED
ADMINISTRATIVE TRUTH AND NO,
NINA JANKOWICZ DOESN'T WANT IT,
PERIOD. IT IS NOT YOUR COUNTRY
AND YOU'RE NOT EVEN GOING TO DO
THIS TO A FREE PEOPLE, PERIOD.
THIS CAN'T HAPPEN. AND WHAT IS
THIS? IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT
IS GOING TO HAPPEN LOOK WHAT DID
HAPPEN. SO NINA JANKOWICZ MADE
IT POSSIBLE FOR PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES TO LIVE FROM THE
DEBATE STAGE ABOUT A STORY THAT
MAY HAVE CHANGED THE OUTCOME OF
ELECTIONS HERE AT OUR ELECTION,
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, SPEAKING
OF DISINFORMATION AND NEVER
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT. THAT IS
BECAUSE HER ROLE HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE TRUTH OR STOPPING
DISINFORMATION. HER JOB IS TO
RESTRICT ANY SPEECH THAT
CHALLENGES JOE BIDEN ON THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY. NOW, YOU WOULD
THINK THAT WOULD BE ILLEGAL IN
THIS COUNTRY AS A FEDERAL
EMPLOYEE BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A
FIRST AMENDMENT, BUT B3 DOESN'T
BELIEVE IN THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
AS SHE WROTE RECENTLY "THE
FREE SPEECH WITH CENSORSHIP
FRAMING IS A FALSE DICHOTOMY."
HERE IS A PRO TIPPED ANYONE WHO
USES FALSE DICHOTOMY IS A MORON
ONE OF THE ACADEMIC PHRASES TO E
DICHOTOMY MEANS THEY WILL
NEVER HAVE TO EXPLAIN WHY
THEIR POSITION IS CORRECT AND
YOURS IS WRONG. IT IS A PULSED
ECONOMY COME AGAIN THAT IS AN
EMPTY PHRASE USED BY LOW IQ
PEOPLE BUT FOR SOME PEOPLE
ALL OF THE SUDDEN, FALSE
DICHOTOMY. HERE IS WHAT NOT HIS
FAULT'S GNOMIC FALSE AT ALL,
THE BILL OF RIGHTS. THIS WILL
COMPETENT IN THAT COUNTRY IS
PREDICATED ON THAT. BUT THE
JOE BIDEN ADMINISTRATIVE TRUTH,
THE FIRST AMENDMENT NO LONGER
APPLIES IN THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE
RUSSIA AND SYSTEMIC RACISM, WAT
>> IT IS CLEAR ACTORS LIKE
RUSSIA ARE USING THOSE INTERNAL
PICTURES AND SYSTEMIC RACIST AND
THINGS LIKE ECONOMIC INEQUALITY
TO AMPLIFY THESE ISSUES AND
REALLY MAKE US DISTRUST THE
SYSTEM. >> Tucker: SO WE
REACHED OUT TO DHS
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY WITH
SPEECH ABOUT HER PLAN TO CENSOR
YOU FROM WHAT IS TRUE. AND THEY
ASSURED US THAT FOLKS LIKE HUMAN
SMUGGLING AND RUSH OF ON
UKRAINE. AND SUDDENLY YOU LEARN
ABOUT THE BORDER FOR RUSSIA OR
UKRAINE. IT IS YOUR JOB. YOU ARE
AN ADULT AND CAN READ IT
WHENEVER YOU WANT. BUT OF COURSE
IT'S NOT ABOUT THAT ANYWAY, IF
YOU READ NINA JANKOWICZ'S BOOK
SHE WAS HIRED TO POLICE DOMESTIC
USE. I HAVE HOPED WE COULD
CHANGE THE NORMS BY WHICH ONLINE
ECOSYSTEM IS GOVERNED, SHE WROTE
AND TYPICALLY, THIS IS THOSE THT
CANNOT WRITE ENGLISH. LATER
IN THE BOOK SHE ENCOURAGES WOMEN
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT IF THEY SEE
SOMETHING THEY DON'T LIKE ON
TWITTER, SHE CALLED THAT AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN THE
DENORMALIZATION OF WOMEN'S
TREATMENT. IT IS HARD TO BELIEVE
OUR SYSTEM PRODUCES PEOPLE LIKE
THIS. SHE IS AN ILLITERATE
FASCIST. IN ANOTHER BOOK, SHE
MADE IT CLEAR SHE IS NOT IN
FAVOR OF SOCIAL MEDIA WHEN IT
ALLOWS CONSERVATIVES TO SPEAK
FREELY. THROUGH THE MIC SO SHE
DEVOTES AN ENTIRE CHAPTER TO
POLAND WITH DIGITAL AFFAIRS.
POLISH OFFICIALS SAY IT WAS A
WAY TO DEAL WITH BUT ONLINE
CENSORSHIP ON SOCIAL NETWORKS.
BUT SHE IS AGAINST THAT. SHE IS
AGAINST THE ANTICENSORSHIP
PROGRAM AND FOR CENSORSHIP. SHE
WROTE THAT POLIN IS MAKING A BIG
MISTAKE IN PULLING BACK
CENSORSHIP AND WE ARE QUOTING.
POLIN'S NEARSIGHTEDNESS IS
LIVING US EXTREMELY VULNERABLE,
SHE WROTE AND THE SOLUTION SHE
WROTE BACK AS FOR THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT TO "LEAD OVERSIGHT OF
PEOPLE WHO DISAGREE WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ON TWITTER." SO
THE TRUTH WAS NEVER THE GOAL.
AND WE ARE QUOTING AGAIN "WE ARE
NOT SURE EFFECTS CAN PREVAIL
OVER DISINFORMATION, NINA
JANKOWICZ WROTE BUT WE MUST
ADDRESS SOCIAL MEDIA." WE SHOULD
BE TOTALLY CLEAR, THE MEANS OF
THE DISTRIBUTION OF INFORMATION
ARE THE KEY TO HER THEY ARE
ROLE. IT IS ALL THEY HAVE PEER
THEY HAVE NOTHING BUT THAT. IF
YOU KNEW WHAT WAS ACTUALLY GOING
ON, YOU WOULDN'T PUT UP WITH
THIS FOR A SECOND. AND THEY KNOW
THAT. AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION KNEW THAT NINA
JANKOWICZ WROTE ALL OF THAT
SPEAR THAT IS WHY THEY HIRED
HER. WHAT YOU ARE SEEING IS A
FULL-SCALE ATTACK ON FREE SPEECH
IN A COUNTRY THAT HAS BEEN FREE
FOR NEARLY 250 YEARS AND IS
HAPPENING AT THE DIRECTION OF
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. WE DO
FEEL THAT BIDEN'S PENTAGON FROM
ANOTHER GROUP OF GUNS AWARDED
$750,000 CONTRACT FOR NEWS
GUARD. THAT CONTRACT IS FOR
MISINFORMATION FINGERPRINTS. THE
ORGANIZATION CLAIMS TO FIGHT
MISINFORMATION BUT IN PRACTICE,
IT IS A CENSORSHIP ORGANIZATION
THAT TARGETS AND HE WENT THAT
CHALLENGES POWER. AND CURRENTLY
PREPARING A BLACKLIST OF SITES
THAT CONTRADICT NATIONAL
SECURITY STATE TALKING POINTS IN
RUSSIA. THIS WEEK NEWS STORE
WROTE A THREATENING EMAIL
INFORMING GRACE ON TEILHARD ARE
SPENT WRITING DISINFORMATION
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT READING
SCRIPT. SO THE MAX BLUMENTHAL
RESPONDED. DO YOU SERIOUSLY
EXPECT US TO GROVEL FOR APPROVAL
FROM THE SAME NATIONAL
SECURITY STATE AND FINANCIAL
OLIGARCHS WITH RATED CNN AS
HIGHLY CREDIBLE NEWS SOURCE AND
BOARD OF ADVISORS AS GROTESQUE
GALLERY OF PROPAGANDISTS,
SPOOKS, DOCUMENTED LIARS, WERE
CRIMINALS WHO NEVER FACE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THEIR
ACTIONS. KIND OF OVERHEATED
LANGUAGE, IS IT TRUE? YEAH,
EVERY WORD OF IT. SO WHEN
JOE BIDEN SENSORS COMP, THAT IS
THE WAY YOU RESPOND, HEY, PAL,
UP YOURS. YOU WENT
DISINFORMATION? HERE YOU GO. YOU